hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today I'm going to be
sharing some final thoughts on the
recently concluded season 2 of one punch
man just a very early warning this video
will contain spoilers so you know
continue on at your own risk
now one punch man season 2 is a series
that has garnered quite a lot of
unfortunate attention primarily due to
the comparison with its first season
produced by the legendary madhouse
whereas this season was produced by
j.c.staff and right at the outset I want
to say that I did not rewatch season 1
before going into season 2 because I
really didn't think that it would be
fair to bring those kind of expectations
into this experience regardless there is
no denying the specter of madhouse that
looms over the entirety of the 12
episodes presented here as one punch man
was a mega hit for the anime world so
season 2 would have had impossible shoes
to fill even if the same production
company were behind it so with all of
that in mind how to season 2 hold up as
a product of its own pretty well I'd say
it was most certainly an enjoyable 12
episodes animated fairly well and with
great vocal performances I think one
thing in particular that was simply
nailed by season two was comedy there
were very few intentional comic beats
that failed to have me laughing and it
made me realize that this world is still
so much fun to be a part of and one
thing that always gets me are the names
of the various monsters with centi kohai
and cindy senpai being some of my
absolute favorites of the season full
credit of which goes to the original
author 1 for having such an obscure yet
direct sense of humor as well as story
but the anime adaptation ran with it
rather nicely as well the highlight of
the season for me was definitely the
addition of Gaara though he was a very
slow burn like when we were first
introduced to him he seemed very bad guy
for the sake of being bad guy you know
the whole I'm not a man I'm a monster so
I'm just going to destroy things with no
good reason but that perception is
gradually dispelled and he becomes
probably the most depth fill character
in the entire season through him we
explore some of the philosophy of what
it is to be a hero and a monster the
former of which has also heavily focused
on by all of the other heroes in one
punch man but Gaara brings quite a nice
unique spin to it having experienced
heroism from the perspective of being
unjustly labelled as a monster which
goes on to become a self-fulfilling
prophecy as he somewhat adopts the idea
of this existence but Gaara especially
in his flashbacks really drew attention
to the darker side of heroics but a lot
of this work being done during the final
episode the series showcasing that the
most popular kid in school had the
innate right to play the hero whilst he
as an outcast was relegated to the
villain and not only that but instead of
playing fairly the hero would bring down
the villain through unbalanced means in
Cara's case by being held down by
the kids but this was also nicely
reflected in one of his earlier
childhood observations where he argues
that a villain I think his name was a
crab demon was actually pretty amazing
for holding his own against so many
heroes but he's often something that
I've thought about because generally the
villains are much much more impressive
than the heroes which is why they all
need to team up to beat them me maybe
not so much in one punch man because
Saitama but in most other media although
initially I wasn't quite able to make
the leap from this idea to Cara's modern
day profession as a hero hunter but when
you realize that he quite purposely
doesn't kill them it does make a tinge
more sense and of course it's character
is made all the more complex by the fact
that despite calling himself a monster
he refuses to align himself with a more
traditional view of monsters it leaves
him in this wonderful gray area that
made him a really captivating presence
to watch on screen and of course all of
his action was fantastic and he was just
a real gem for this season in general
he's not the only one though because I
feel like the more extended casts get a
huge chance to shine here another
example of which being metal bat who
skyrocketed to being one of my favorite
characters in the entire series after I
saw his episodes he just exuded raw
amazingness and really left me with a
feeling of yes this is what an s-class
hero is which is very important in the
season where we are constantly
questioning the very idea of heroism
even our protagonist Saitama has to deal
with some degree where as usual his own
biggest challenge being himself I come
to think of it this season if one punch
man really did not see a whole lot of
Saitama his primary action was becoming
involved in the martial arts tournament
and yeah he swept in and one shot some
monsters here and there as per usual but
he wasn't at all a major focus which
oddly enough I think only helps the
series the real drama and action of one
punch man comes from people undergoing
legitimate struggles and there's only so
much you can do with Saitama struggle
with boredom so as much as I loved him I
didn't really miss him all that much
when he wasn't there although it was
still incredibly satisfying to see him
show up and wreak face every time he was
in a position to do so and I suppose I
should also mention the character of
sudio who was an interesting addition to
the world as I did very much enjoy
delving into the pursuit of strength
outside of the hero profession and
Sudhir provided some challenging ideas
but I really liked that when everything
was said and done even he was left
crying out for a hero to help him
finally realizing what the true purpose
of a hero is however despite these
fantastic characters I do think that
season two suffers from a narrative
perspective and yes I get that this is
going to happen because we're adapting a
manga here rather than specifically
catering a product for seasonal
television but in the end all that
really matters is the result for me and
it was a bit jarring at times one of the
better examples is the very first
episode which focuses heavily on the
character of
and his false heroics oh no now there
was nothing wrong with this episode on
its own it presents some great ideas and
it's entertaining but it's placed in an
awkward spot being the opener of the
season because I suppose that after
waiting what three or four years what I
wanted was something more Saitama or
Jenna's focused to bring me back into
this world and so kicking things off
with this in-depth exploration of King
just hit me as a bit off and once again
I get it that's probably how it happened
in the manga but from the perspective of
just watching the anime it's it's it is
what it is but expanding our gaze
overall the season felt very incomplete
there were two major plot lines
established being guru and the plans of
the monster Association and by the end
of the season neither were in any way
close to being resolved for the third
time once again I understand this is not
the fault of the anime as that was the
manga material they had to develop and
while I haven't read the manga my
understanding is that by the end of
season two we are essentially brought up
to date with it as it's currently
dealing with the two aforementioned
thoughts that's fine but it doesn't
really change the overall feeling of
this season not really having an ending
in fact it actually feels like the
halfway point of a season you know the
threat is established now and it's time
to kick into serious mode to deal with
it so it left me wanting more and not in
a good way like well that was a
satisfying series I certainly hope we
get another bit in more of a you just
ended the story halfway through and now
I don't know if I'll ever actually get
to see the end of it because it could
realistically be another three or four
years before we see a third outing if at
all so yeah it's next to impossible for
me to be satisfied with season 2 from a
narrative perspective but at the same
time like I said it was still highly
enjoyable because of the wonderful
characters of this world but now I guess
we should address the animation and
here's the thing even without comparing
j.c.staff to madhouse there were moments
where what the season provides is simply
lackluster for the most part the
animation was fine and even greatly
enjoyable but there are certain segments
of action that feel like they just
really didn't have that much put into
them for example in episode 2 when
Saitama is fighting foo buki there is a
point in which she sandwiches him in
concrete and the way in which he is
visually depicted to break out of it and
he is exceptionally underwhelming it's
just a basic flash of light and then
some slow-moving rock fragments with an
even slower moving entirely still image
of Saitama this moment is missing any
semblance of oomph and impact and it's
not the only time that the action feels
lacking either
there are moments like that scattered
throughout the entirety of these twelve
episodes that just make me want more
from what I'm watching and I have to
admit some of that may be because of how
funny I remember what madhouse did with
season 1 but for the most part I do
believe that these instances are just
plain and simple lesser quality
animation
and that's a shame but I guess that's
what we have luckily I don't feel like
these instances impact the overall
experience too much yes they are a bit
jarring but as a whole the animation
feels you know quite solid and in the
end I did thoroughly enjoy my time with
this second outing of one punch man the
only major detriment in my eyes was the
narrative itself but once again just
experiencing these characters once more
in this world makes up for it for me
anyway but that pretty much does it for
my final thoughts on season 2 of one
punch man if you enjoyed this video and
the content this channel produce in
general then please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon it could
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video
we'll action or subscribe because it
also helps spot this channel and
incredible amount and if you'd like to
join the fun and anytime then please do
head over to my discord server where a
wide array of shenanigan me takes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your own thoughts on one
punch man
season 2 this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
you
[Music]